i think sarah and i were compelled to do
this project both
pam just like you and hey we're just
like you because we felt we owe
something to our teenage selves
in your special that where you're
introducing this new ep
you know you you and your guests talk
about would your high school self think
you're cool kind of thing like would
your high school self like you now and
all that
it's such a cool exploration i think
like everybody
in the world we all look back at our
teenage selves and we go
like we cringe you know we're so
embarrassed by the things we thought and
we said and we felt and
i think for us our journey in exploring
our teenage selves the last couple years
was a huge realization that our teenage
selves are just us
but you know younger and we need to
express a lot of love and compassion for
our younger selves all of us
collectively in the world
so to take those songs of our younger
selves and give them to
you know really amazing artists and have
them
continue this evolution and and to
create a new sonic landscape was
just kind of a thrilling experience and
i imagine teenage tegan and sarah
their minds would be blown by this whole
thing they just i i
no doubt that those kids in that garage
writing those songs would be like
we are unrecognizable to them i'm sure
hello
hello hello i'm right
here i was thinking about the whole
picture day thing
i was like oh my god like it might be
awful like
you have do you have a favorite or like
even like a worst picture day picture
that you remember
the truth is that the grade 10 school
photo
is what came to sort of i don't know
like
it sort of seemed like the most like
this project and what we were trying to
capture
um we're both both tegan and i are
making the most
unfriendly teenager face you can
possibly imagine
um i'm wearing a nirvana t-shirt because
that was
that was the era it was 1995 and i have
like a yin yang necklace
like a choker like super 90s hair split
down the middle i mean i
i sort of had that quintessential 90s
um like someone you would kick out of
the 7-eleven
because you thought they were
shoplifting look